well as we've already been discussing on
wednesday the state of the country's
finances will be laid bare by the
chancellor and
it's not going to be pretty
three-quarters of a million people have
already lost their jobs during the
pandemic
the government's reportedly considering
both tax rises and a wage freeze for
public sector workers
we can speak now to the general
secretary of the tuc francis
o grady well we'll be talking to the
chancellor directly after you
and how concerned are you by these
reports that there could be a public
sector pay fees in the cards
very concerned sophie because millions
of key workers cared for us
during the crisis and continue to care
for us and i think it's time that we
cared for them
and we saw ministers join millions of us
out on the doorsteps clapping
firefighters
refuse collectors social care workers
i don't think this would be the time to
reward them with a real pay cut
at the same time though um public sector
workers are paid seven percent more than
those in the private sector according to
the omans
and we are facing a jobs crisis in the
private sector three-quarters of a
million people
already losing their jobs since the
beginning of the pandemic 10 million on
furlough
okay people in the public sector may be
facing pay restraint
but those in the private sector are
facing no jobs at all
well let's put the record straight the
ons have said that if you adjust for
age and qualifications actually the pay
difference between the public and
private sector
is zero but it won't help anybody
if we end up depressing pay anywhere
what we need is to create good jobs and
lift living standards you know the prime
minister
only in june promised that this is the
end
of austerity there would be no more
austerity
surely the government doesn't think that
it can reintroduce austerity for the
very people who put their health
and in some cases lives on the line
to help the rest of us and i think it's
you know common sense if you want to
motivate
a workforce uh when we're still facing
the second wave of the pandemic
and we're gonna have a tough winter we
all know that
the last thing you do is threaten to cut
their pay so
there's still time for the government to
step back and i would encourage them to
think again
uh this this is not smart politics it's
morally obscene and it's bad economics
too
uh well we'll be putting some of that to
the chancellor uh in just a few moments
and matsuwatka of the public and
commercial services union said on friday
if rishi sunak fails to pay public
sector workers properly
there will be widespread anger and
industrial action cannot be ruled out
would it be responsible to go on strike
during a pandemic
i'm really conscious of the feeling out
there that
people only uh or governments only seem
to recognize the true value of labour
when it's withdrawn but of course there
is time to sort this out
nobody can rule anything out at the
moment but what i am saying
and asking for is that the government
stands by key workers
respects the contribution they are
continuing to make
recognises that this is absolutely the
wrong time to be talking about pay cuts
and instead we need to start talking
about fairness and by the way
even in terms of their own interests
many of those red war constituencies
you know are disproportionately
dependent on key workers jobs
the worst thing to do if you want to
raise demands in the economy
is to cut their pay they are the very
people who spend their pay packets in
local
businesses and shops you
really don't want to pull away that
demand in the economy now on the
contrary what we should be
absolutely focused on is preventing
unemployment
and creating good green jobs in the
parts of the country that need the most
okay
and just finally and we're expecting of
course the prime minister to announce
tomorrow
that the lockdown in england will end
but we're going to be going into a new
stricter tier system now of course we
also
know just how difficult 2020 has been
for many businesses
many shops pumps restaurants so
dependent and reliant
on that christmas trade we know many
people have been shopping online at
places like
amazon as a result of the lockdown
company you've been very critical of in
the past
how important is it do you think for
high street businesses to be able to
continue trading
once lockdown ends i think it's
really important that we do everything
we can to ensure that the millions of
people who are still working
can do so safely i think that would
build confidence
and keep many businesses running you
know in our local high streets there are
people doing
takeaways and so on but we need to make
sure that workplaces are safe
that's how you build confidence and just
just one other thing you mentioned
amazon
let's not forget when we're talking
about apparently
cutting the real pay of hard-working
key workers that uh we've seen billions
go out the door
in contracts uh asking very little in
return in terms of due diligence let
alone
a decent treatment of their workforce
so you know again i think i am appealing
to people's sense of fairness
and justice here uh that you know as a
country
we cannot look ourselves in the mirror
and cut
the pay of some of our hard-working
key workers exemptions for the nhs
that's great but let's talk about social
care let's talk about
prison officers refuse collectors
delivery drivers
shop workers all the people who've kept
britain going and should be rewarded for
it
okay francesca grady always good to talk
we'll be talking to you chancellor
about some of those points you raised
thank you